s
avec Olivier Bachand.
- La promesse, c'était de
planter 2 milliards d'arbres.
- Hum-hum.
- Vous en avez planté combien
jusqu'à maintenant?
JUSTIN TRUDEAU, chef,
Parti libéral du Canada
- On en a planté... bien
d'abord, planter des arbres,
faut les pousser d'abord.
Ça prend un certain montant
pour... on peut pas tout
simplement planter des graines,
il faut planter des arbustes.
(rire d'Anne-Marie)
- Combien d'arbres ont été
plantés jusqu'à maintenant?
♪ ♪ ♪
Au moins 800 000.
- Merci d'être là!
- C'est une promesse que
les libéraux ont faite
à Montréal pendant la campagne
électorale de 2019.
- Le changement arrive.
Si vous l'aimez ou non.
- Ce jour-là, des centaines
de milliers de personnes ont
manifesté pour le climat
aux côtés de Greta Thunberg.
(cris de la foule)
- Un gouvernement libéral réélu
plantera 2 milliards d'arbres au
cours des 10 prochaines années.
- En février dernier, Ottawa a
lancé un premier appel d'offres
pour la plantation de
30 millions d'arbres
d'ici la fin de l'année.
Combien ont réellement été
plantés jusqu'à présent?
On l'ignore avec précision
parce que le ministère
des Ressources naturelles est
incapable de répondre
à la question.
Cet été, sept ententes qui
prévoient la plantation
de 2 millions d'arbres ont été
dévoilées publiquement.
On a contacté les groupes
sélectionnés et on a réussi
à confirmer qu'au moins
808 200 arbres ont été plantés
dans le cadre du programme, mais
il pourrait y en avoir plus.
Les libéraux auront seulement
rempli 1,5 % de leur promesse
s'ils parviennent à planter
30 millions d'arbres
cette année, comme prévu.
Il va rester 1,97 milliard
d'arbres à planter d'ici 2030.
C'est 246 millions d'arbres
par année. La cadence devra donc
s'accélérer.
Le gouvernment fédéral a mis
de côté plus de 3 milliards $
pour la plantation de
2 milliards d'arbres. Mais selon
le directeur parlementaire
du budget, ça va coûter environ
deux fois plus c